in this prisoner swap why did Russia get
such a better deal our choices was
Britney or no one at all bringing home
one American or no American at all and
that's that National athlete we gave up
a prolific arms dealer who was convicted
of trying to kill Americans who was
called The Merchant of death whether
you're a sports team or a nation trading
a terrorist for dead bodies or an arms
dealer for a wnb player the asymmetry of
that creates a situation where the other
country they go boy look what we can get
back
we can get our freaking crazed Merchant
of death arms dealer we can get him back
all we had to do was hijack this WNBA
player that nobody cares about